what if we have 15 or 20 percent
inflation by by november or december uh
we're talking about an alarming problem
where you know the poor and working
class in our country won't be able to
afford the routine staples of life but
we're then talking also about what
happens when it finally bursts and when
it bursts usually you have dramatic
rises in interest rates but you also
have dramatically high unemployment
so i'm concerned about the future of our
country and i think we need to get our
house in order
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
one of the senators from the great state
of kentucky senator rand paul welcome
back to the reuben report
thanks for having me
all right so we crunched some numbers
before we had you on today i've got the
papers right in front of me here now we
just gave ukraine 40 billion according
to my numbers we don't have 40 billion
am i correct
no even before we started you know
lavishing large sums on the covid
bailout we were already about a trillion
dollars short in our ordinary expenses
so to pay for medicare medicaid food
stamps social security and the military
we're about a trillion dollars short
every year now in the last two years we
added an extra four or five trillion
just to really show people we could
spend money like crazy but our normal
expenses were a trillion dollars short
and so that's the question i ask where
does the 40 billion come from who do you
get it from do you get it from do we
borrow it from china to send it to
ukraine um really we borrow it from
china we borrow it from england we
bought it from japan but a lot of it we
print
and all the republicans up here seem to
be concerned about inflation but they
don't seem to be concerned about where
they're going to find the 40 billion
they sent to ukraine
are you shocked how few republicans
decided to push back against this i
think what it was 14 total if i'm not
mistaken
yeah it was a small number in the senate
so you know it's about 20 percent of the
republicans about 10 percent of the
senate and over the house there are
about 57 republicans but frankly i look
at the list and i say you know what i'm
not really going to be supporting or
working for any people who say that they
are for a constitutional foreign policy
and yet are for shoveling money out the
door you know we do have problems at
home i'm worried about us becoming
venezuela frankly i'm worried about us
destroying our currency and i see no
everybody that looks at this even the
people who look at it from the
traditional central banking point of
view say we're so far behind the curve
they're not sure how this is going to
end because when interest rates are
still so low and they've been so slow to
start increasing the interest rates
many people are predicting there isn't
going to be a quick end inflation that
could get much worse what if we have 15
or 20 inflation by by november or
december uh we're talking about an
alarming problem where you know the poor
and working class in our country won't
be able to afford the routine staples of
life but we're then talking also about
what happens when it finally bursts and
when it bursts usually you have dramatic
rises in interest rates but you also
have dramatically high unemployment
so i'm concerned about the future of our
country and i think we need to get our
house in order
so right we're not very good at getting
our house in order we seem to want to
get other people's houses in order and
we don't do that very well either this
40 billion though one of the things that
you brought up in the last week or so
was uh hey guys how about we get some
receipts on this how about we find out
exactly where it's going what you're
going to be spending it on who's getting
the kickbacks etc etc and pretty much
nobody has an answer for you is that is
that fair to say or is that an
overstatement
well there's something called the
special inspector general of afghanistan
reconstruction he's been doing this for
several years now he has a whole team
involved but afghanistan as you know we
decided the best way to exit was to exit
in infamy and screw the whole thing up
but leave about 80 billion dollars worth
of equipment there but this guy's an
amazing he has an amazing team at
looking at the waist and he at least
stops some of the criminality and i do
mean direct criminality there are
thieves there are worldwide thieves who
suck up u.s taxpayer dollars and then
they run
one quick example they built a 90
million dollar hotel where they got 90
million dollars for a hotel in kabul
they spent probably 10 million erected
in edifice the basic outline of it and
then the guy took off somewhere in the
middle east and took the rest of the
money it still sits there it's just an
empty edifice it didn't quite get built
and so this kind of stuff goes on and on
and i thought this guy would be perfect
his name's john sopko he's done a great
job at looking at afghan waste and
catching the criminals well everybody
came up to me at first and they said oh
it's a great idea republicans and
democrats but then they got wind of who
it was going to be
and so the uber hawks in the republican
party said oh we hate him because he's
always embarrassing us with all our
follies as we go around the world he
finds where the money's being stolen
he's an embarrassment to the hawks and
actually guess what there are hawks in
both parties so they both ganged up and
said oh
no we can't do this we need to let biden
pick his own person which would be
starting from scratch and would take six
months to a year might never happen and
they would probably pick someone who's
weak and will not do the job so it was a
fight but it shows how much concern they
have they do not have concern for the
money these people are not fiscally
conservative and really they wound up
just calling me names calling me an
isolationist and it's like well no i'm a
fiscal conservative and they're not
fiscally conservative
no i mean you were literally asking for
receipts that's pretty much it in a more
broad sense in terms of what's going on
in ukraine
do you i know we are technically not at
war and we often now go to wars without
declaring war and and all of that and i
know your stance on that and i'm with
you
but are we at war at this point at what
point when you endlessly fund a war
are you actually at war
i think you're at war when your enemy
perceives you at war and attacks you so
there's a possibility and we don't know
this if everything goes well the
ukrainians keep fighting well and they
push the russians out and then the war
ends everybody will have said it was all
worthwhile but it's just like finland
and sweden joining nato
might be a good thing if nobody attacks
them and it's defensive
but it also might be a bad thing what if
we decide that we're going to locate
nuclear weapons in finland for 50 60
years they've said they don't want
nuclear weapons there you know what if
that's part of being a nato part of
being a nato is sort of accepting the
weapons that u.s sends to you so
i think we don't know what if the
provocation does lead to a nuclear
exchange you know if
a european capital is bombed or a u.s
capital or a large city is bombed with
nuclear weapons will people then look
back in retrospect and say well maybe we
shouldn't have pushed them so hard maybe
we shouldn't have insisted that ukraine
be part of nato
and you know there are many smart minds
who have written about this george
kennan's probably one of the most famous
diplomats of the last century said it
was a mistake to advance and to provoke
russia with uh creating nato larger and
larger so did kissinger so have many
others so did james matlock uh who was
um
the
ambassador under the first george bush
to russia so a lot of smart people
written on this but now if you say
anything they say oh you're sympathizing
with putin even when i try to preface
every talk by saying there's no
justification for putin's attack there's
no sympathy for putin at all and then i
hope the ukrainians win but it still
doesn't mean we should ignore the
fundamental causes of war and try to at
least revisit this so we know how to
prevent war in the future i mean even in
the end if the ukrainians win there will
be a destroyed country
ukraine will be destroyed and then who's
going to pay to rebuild ukraine they're
already talking about us paying the 40
billion that we are spending on the war
effort now they're saying that'll last
till september
they're going to be back in september
asking for more money but the bill when
we go to rebuild ukraine russia destroys
it and they're going to laugh all the
way as we go and spend a couple hundred
billion rebuilding ukraine so
yeah we just don't have the money we're
out of money for all the stuff we
promised the american people
are you surprised that some of your
colleagues guys that i'm sure you like
and that that that are smart and decent
human beings that they just don't get
the basic obvious stuff that you just
laid out there that they don't get once
you start throwing money at it you're
gonna throw more money at it and it's
gonna keep going and we've done this
before and we're going to do it again
there's a disconnect between the people
and there's a disconnect in particular
between the republican primary and the
republican party voters and who they get
they get a lot of people who promise
them many things and then don't follow
through republicans at home and the
rotary club will say i'm fiscally
conservative and they come up here and
they vote for all the spending they go
to the rotary club and says i'm with you
if you elect me we will get rid of
obamacare
seven republicans in the senate came
back and voted to keep obamacare we had
the identical vote under president
obama when he vetoed it and every
republican voted for it president trump
came in power and said he would sign the
law i introduced the exact same
legislation is almost word for word the
same and seven republicans who voted to
get rid of it under obama voted to keep
foot under trump when we could have
gotten rid of obamacare this is a
problem it's a perpetual problem but
that hawkishness some people define
conservatism as hawkishness not fiscal
conservatism not balanced budgets they
are conservative only in the sense that
they are for a bigger military and uh
more might and that we should spread
freedom around the world and these are
the george w bush republicans and
frankly it's one of the reasons why i
leaned
more towards trump on so much of this is
that he did have a good head on his
shoulders and he had a certain reticence
to get involved around the world he
wasn't afraid he was strong but at the
same time he wasn't eager for uh the
beginnings of a world war and i think in
some ways he was like reagan he actually
he worried about a nuclear war and did
not want to to be the person who
presided over the destruction of the
world through nuclear war so he was not
eager to sort of
you know i think provoke war around the
world i think i mentioned this to you
last time you were on but your support
for trump uh was one of the things that
finally got me to support him because i
thought all right here's one of the guys
on the short list of people i respect in
the senate and and he's you know one of
trump's main defenders right now so
let's move to some other stuff real
quick uh this ministry of truth that
seems to have collapsed you had a rather
extraordinary exchange with hhs
secretary mayorkas so i want to play
just a little bit
do you think the steele dossier included
russian disinformation
senator um
that's not a question that i'm equipped
to answer the uh it was in the public
news it was a you may have heard of it
the mueller investigation it was a 32
million investigation that went over a
couple of years
uh horowitz was an investigator general
and he looked at the fbi's activity in
the beginning of this and what the fbi
concluded was that there were fbi agents
throughout this period of time who
concluded
that yes the dossier was full of russian
disinformation
so let's say it is russian
disinformation you say your new
disinformation governance board is going
to help the public with this information
you claim it's not going to be about
domestic it's going to be about
foreigners and those evil russians
so here's my question the fbi concludes
that the steele dossier was full of
russian disinformation
cnn propagated this disinformation
gladly for years and years
the difference i guess between your
opinion and our opinion is that as
despicable as it is that cnn propagated
this disinformation
i wouldn't shut them down i wouldn't
lecture them i wouldn't put it on a
government website that cnn's wrong for
propagating disinformation
the problem you have is you're not even
willing to admit i mean we can't even
have an agreement on what the fbi said
was disinformation how do you propose
that you're going to have an office of
disinformation governance
if you see the problem in even
determining what is disinformation well
senator because
our work is not
focused on disinformation writ large
where we the department of homeland
security become involved
is when there's a connectivity between
disinformation
and threats
to the security of the homeland well
that's what the russians might be
considered that you mentioned the
russians the other day when you tried to
pivot away from this being about
censorship i think you've got no idea
what disinformation is and i don't think
the government's capable of it do you
know who the greatest propagator of
disinformation in the history of the
world is the us government are you
familiar with mcnamara the pentagon
papers
are you familiar with george w bush and
the weapons of mass destruction are you
familiar with iran contra
i mean think of all the debates and
disputes we've had over the last
50 years in our country
we work them out by debating them we
don't work them out by the government
being the arbiter i don't want you guard
rails i want you to have nothing to do
with speech you think we can't determine
you know speech by traffickers is
disinformation you think the american
people are so stupid they need you to
tell them what the truth is you can't
even admit what the truth is with the
steele dossier i don't trust government
to figure out what the truth is
government is largely disseminating
disinformation so when i was playing
that before the show for my guys we were
all cracking up because it's like this
guy i mean you cannot even agree on what
disinformation is that was your whole
point there that none of this makes any
sense beyond that it's against the first
amendment let's say
yeah the the first amendment and
constitutionality doesn't work with
these people very well so i tried to get
him at least to admit that he really
didn't even agree with the fbi on what
disinformation was we had the
christopher steele dossier the fbi now
admits that it was russian
disinformation in fact christopher
steele said he got the information from
a source in the kremlin yeah i think it
might have been a source giving him
disinformation so anyway i asked him
about it i love the deflection he's like
well uh you know i'm not an expert in
that and i say well do you read the
newspaper you know we spent 30 million
dollars on it and we spent countless
hours on television talking about it
everybody on your side said it was
russian collusion that trump colluded
but it turns out that was disinformation
and i said if that's disinformation
are you going to go to cnn and shut down
cnn because for the last three years
they've been promoting disinformation
and i said for the record i'm not for
that right i say turn the channel if you
don't like cnn and they're full of
disinformation which they are turn the
channel but uh i'm afraid of any kind of
government organization even one that
would go after the disinformation of cnn
i don't want the government anywhere
near determining what truth is it's not
as easy as a job as you think you hear
facts on both sides it's like being a
juror or a journalist or even a
scientist you hear a lot of the facts on
each side and then you try to draw a
conclusion but it's not always easy and
definable and something that somebody
from government could be trusted with
that job in all your years in the senate
have you ever seen anything that was
more direct assault on the first
amendment than the idea of this proposed
ministry of truth i mean the idea that
the government would somehow regulate or
punish or
depress certain speech
i'm worried about it because there are
people on the left and the right sort of
promoting this and i tell my audiences
all the time now back at home because
they're really proud of me on fighting
the ministry of truth but i said look
there's some on the right who are
setting up legislation where there would
be government boards because they hate
big tech so much that they want over
oversight of big tech and so we have to
be very worried about right or the left
getting involved with speech and people
need to remember there are tons and tons
of choices your podcast didn't exist 20
years ago you know when i was a kid you
had three networks you didn't really
have a conservative radio you had abc
nbc and cbs the news was identical it
was a very subtle form of leftism it
wasn't in your face but it was all
liberal but there were no other choices
we've got all kinds of choices on
television now on the right we have
conservative radio we dominate the radio
sphere we have the podcast sphere so i
don't i don't worry about us getting
enough message out and i tell people i'm
kind of tired of everybody that
complains about twitter quit using it go
somewhere else you know i left youtube i
haven't yet left twitter but i left
youtube and came to rumble because i i
don't want to support a group that
believes in censorship and if the others
continue to censor me i'll leave them
too
let me ask you one other thing because i
know you're limited on time i've come to
the conclusion at this point that this
administration cannot be this inept that
all of the problems with supply chain
and inflation and the bungling of
ukraine and all of the stuff
this cannot be ineptitude this has to be
intentional
am i am i being am i overstepping do you
think on that
only if their party is a death wish
because i think they're going to get
steamrolled in november because of the
inflation no i think they
they really don't really truly
understand inflation maybe they're dumb
enough to believe that greed causes
inflation but inflation comes from debt
and it comes from the federal reserve
buying the debt and all that new demand
all that new money that flows into the
system bids prices up with gasoline they
made it worse by also restricting the
supply
so price is supply and demand you
predict
you reduce the supply increase the
demand and boy do you have rip roaring
inflation but we've borrowed more money
in the last two years ever even as a
percentage of gdp if you try to quantify
it that way more money than we ever have
before and you even have democrat
economists there was the furman came out
in the last couple of days one of
obama's economist saying it was a
mistake they juiced up the economy too
much and he said i warned him at the
time so there are some reasonable
rational democrat economists maybe one
or two but anyway there's a few of them
out there and they're even admitting
what a disaster this is so i don't think
they do it on purpose i think there
there is a a high degree of incompetence
on this and maybe they just didn't
believe we haven't had inflation since
the 70s maybe they thought it just
disappeared it wasn't coming back we've
had inflation but we haven't had
this kind of inflation since the late
70s and maybe they thought it wouldn't
come you had to remember you had all
these people talking about the new
monetary theory and all this you can
spend and borrow as you much i mean dick
cheney was part of that too deficits
don't matter there are big government
republicans that have loved deficits
forever too but
no i don't think it's intentional but i
do think that it's enormous and maybe
bigger than anybody has predicted i
think it gets a lot bigger even before
november
well senator i thank you for being one
of the reasonable and rational people we
got in government it is a short list i
appreciate your time look forward to
talking to you soon
thanks for having me
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell